hi I'm Ryan and someone requested that I
watch the latest trailer first 300 rise
of an empire I'm going to check this
trailer out you know I actually thought
it was gonna be like it's some shitty
looking film but then when I saw the
trailer I was like this phone was pretty
[ __ ] cool actually so you know they
got a lot of the original cast back and
I haven't seen the latest trailer yet I
tend to get to movies right when they
start so I saved the trailer time for
the internet anyway let's check this
[ __ ] out
heard it's based on the Xerces something
like that Frank Miller calling I just
don't want you know haters commenting
saying like you [ __ ] up the origin of
this story when you said something a
little off can't go through that water
the exist
muscle
still looks beautiful Leonidas and the
brave 300 are dead
have I not given enough for your dream
of a united Greece mr. Creason a king a
husband of mmm yes
you know prestress next night
God's gonna feed the Greeks
you will be
taking the music being a story looks
better
you know just
let it be shown we chose to die on our
feet rather than labor on our knees
oh yes I saw the second trailer on IMAX
3d and it was like legit 3d and that is
the best trailer I've seen and the story
looks better because I was a thing I
didn't really care for and 300 like the
action and all that [ __ ] and the visuals
were obviously dynamite but one actually
came to like the story I really didn't
give two shits this one looks like I
might get some emotion in there you know
some cinematic escapism because I don't
want to face my real problems